يقول مسؤولو الصحة في ولاية ميسيسيبي إن
مكالمات مركز مكافحة السموم تتسلق
لأن ما يرونه هو أن
السكان يتناولون شيئًا يسمى
الإيفرمكتين وهو دواء مضاد
للطفيليات للخيول والأبقار لعلاج
فيروس كورونا ، وقد أدى ذلك إلى
دخول مستشفى واحد ، يمكنك أن تكون واضحًا بشأنه.  الأمريكيون
يتعاطون هذا الدواء
جيدًا وهو بريانا الذي يفطر القلب عند
سماعه واسمحوا لي فقط أن أقول بوضوح شديد
أن الإيفرمكتين ليس علاجًا موصى به
لـ covid19 فهو ليس
دواء موصى به للوقاية من covid19
أفضل حماية لدينا ضد covid19
هو اللقاح وإذا  تحصل على covid19
لدينا بالفعل علاجات تعمل
من المنشطات إلى الأجسام المضادة وحيدة النسيلة
وغيرها من العلاجات ولكن الإيفرمكتين
ليس واحدًا منها وبريانا ما
يسلط الضوء عليه هذا هو مجرد التكلفة العميقة
للتضليل الصحي في الوقت الحالي ،
لقد رأينا أن المعلومات الصحية
الخاطئة  مشكلة لسنوات ولكن نطاق السرعة
والتطور الذي
ينتشر ويؤثر على  الصحة غير
مسبوقة حقًا وهي تحدث
إلى حد كبير بمساعدة
ومنصات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، وهذا هو السبب في
أنني قدمت قبل بضعة أسابيع استشاريًا لجراحًا عامًا
بشأن المعلومات الصحية الخاطئة
جزئيًا مطالبة الشركات بالمساءلة لتقول إن
عليها اتخاذ المزيد من الإجراءات
المسؤولية
عن هذه المعلومات الصحية الخاطئة على
مواقعهم لأنه يمكنني أن أسألك إلى
هذه النقطة ، هل يمكنني أن أسألك عن هذه النقطة سيدي
لأن Facebook قال في نهاية هذا الأسبوع
ونعم لقد كنت واضحًا في هذا ولكن
Facebook قال في نهاية هذا الأسبوع أن قصة إخبارية
تقوض الثقة في
لقاحات فيروس كورونا كانت الرابط الأكثر
شيوعًا في الولايات المتحدة خلال الربع الأول
من عام 2021. لذا فقد أصدرت هذا
التحذير بالتأكيد بشأن المعلومات الخاطئة ،
ما رأيك في هذه الأخبار
جيدًا أعتقد أنها تعزز ما
عرفناه منذ فترة طويلة وهو  أن
هناك الكثير من المعلومات المضللة
المتداولة على هذه المواقع وانظر ،
فهل ستعرف بسهولة القول إن المواقع
قد أدركت أن هذا يمثل
تحديًا  لقد صعدوا للقيام ببعض الأشياء
لتقليل انتشار المعلومات
المضللة وأنا أعزو لهم الفضل في ذلك ولكن هذا ليس
كافيًا تقريبًا لأنه لا يزال هناك
قدر هائل من المعلومات الخاطئة
المتداولة هناك أشخاص
ينشرون المعلومات الخاطئة
بشكل كبير ويستمرون في نشرها.  نشر معلومات غير دقيقة
عبر الإنترنت ولا
تزال هناك خوارزميات تستمر في
تقديم المزيد والمزيد من المعلومات الخاطئة
للأشخاص الذين يواجهونها في المرة الأولى ،
هذه أشياء يمكن للشركات
تغييرها ويجب عليها تغييرها وأعتقد أن لديها
مسؤولية أخلاقية للقيام بذلك
بسرعة وشفافية